it was constructive but I raised really
as you can imagine at the top of the
agenda the issue of the cost of living
crisis it's affecting households right
across the UK and particularly
low-income households in Scotland and I
urged them to do more I also urged them
to respect Devolution the foreign
secretary was really clumsy intervention
trying to curtail our external
engagement just the latest example of
the UK government trying to undermine uh
Devolution and of course I raised the
issue of the Scottish whiskey industry
being unfairly treated as well and I was
also very grateful for the UK government
for the Prime Minister giving me a
briefing in the situation in Sudan too
did Independence come up or any
specifics around a potential another
referendum of course I raised that
pretty early on and told the Prime
Minister that I wouldn't stop seeking a
section 30 order that is exactly related
to the issue of just reference in terms
of the undermining of devolution
remember we were elected the SNP on a
mandate to hold another referendum the
Scottish Parliament as a majority has
voted for another referendum the UK
government's continued refusal to deny
the Scottish people their Democratic
choice is one that I'm not prepared to
accept